[Music]
it's michelle from live muffin beauty
science chemistry phd beauty product
nerd and today we are busting hair care
myths i usually bust beauty mist for
free but today's video is sponsored by
pantene even though it is sponsored
everything is my own opinions and
research unfortunately since they're
paying me they expect me to actually do
work
we're going to start by looking at the
scrape test
i don't know if you remember but back in
the day i did a video debunking this
section from five minute crafts they
scraped off some white stuff on hair
with scissors and talked about how hair
products worked it turns out that this
test isn't just some wacky five minute
crafts exclusive but it's actually used
by hairdressers and people selling hair
care products to convince you that their
silicone is building up on your hair so
i thought i'd do a little experiment i
took two samples of hair i washed both
of these with clarifying shampoo that's
meant to remove buildup and i did this
twice to really make sure i clarified
the hair then i put pantene conditioner
on this one only usually when people do
this scrape test they talk about
conditioner with silicones or just
drugstore conditioners with silicones
causing so called buildup there's
usually a few myths around cheap
drugstore versus expensive professional
products involved i blow dry both hair
samples to about 90 dryness then i let
them air dry i'm going to scrape them
here's the pantene one with silicones
lots of white stuff coming off
so if it's silicone buildup we shouldn't
see it with the hair that doesn't have
conditioner here's the hair sample
without conditioner
but we still get the white buildup
coming off if we look through my little
handheld microscope we can see what
looks like microscopic grated parmesan
cheese curls i guess this is a forbidden
snack but you could totally eat hair and
on both of these samples we can see
these long clear curly pieces so it
doesn't look like this white stuff is
built up from conditioner otherwise we
firstly see no white stuff coming off
the clarified hair sample with no
conditioner and we'd see a big
difference in the sorts of residue
coming off the two different samples but
i think these much more high-powered
microscope images that pantene
scientists took of the residue tells us
a bit more about what's going on the
structure of hair is like a cylinder
there's a cortex on the inside and
cuticles on the outside and it's
actually the inside cortex that's
colored that's where all the pigment
lives and on the outside the cuticle
this is the part that has that roof
shingle structure that you've probably
seen in diagrams this is actually
transparent the white waxy residue it is
mostly just the cuticle getting scraped
off you can see the little roof shingles
here so this scraping test isn't a
really good way to check for residue and
if you look at the microscopic images of
the hair afterwards this is what it
looks like it looks like a split end
this test is actually giving you split
ends this scrape test is actually super
damaging so don't do this at home with
your own hair and please don't let
someone who you're paying to make your
hair look nice do this to your hair
either so scraping hair with scissors
doesn't show you whether or not products
are building up on your hair now premium
salon hair care products versus
drugstore products specifically
conditioners there's a myth that
drugstore conditioners leave build up
while salon products don't but the truth
is all conditioning products leave stuff
on and in the hair this is fundamental
to how they work hair is dead the only
living part is the part inside your
scalp the bulb so the hair up near your
scalp the bit that's just come out of
the bulb this is really nice and neat
and it looks a bit like this under a
microscope but hair grows at about 14
centimeters per year this is about 5.5
inches that's down to around here so by
the time your hair reaches here it's
built up about a year's worth of damage
that's 365 days of brushing washing sun
exposure drying it with heat
straightening it with heat and that's if
you don't blast it with bleach like i
did little bits get snapped off the
outside of the cuticle and it ends up
looking a bit like this so you can
imagine the difference between how these
two sections of hair feel closer to your
scalp it feels smooth the longer it is
the rougher it gets and then when you
have these battered surfaces when they
smash against each other then you get
more and more damage to make something
battered feel smooth again sanding it
down and wearing it down even more isn't
a really good approach you have to add
stuff back into the hair to plug up the
gaps and that's exactly what all
conditioning treatments do they fill in
gaps not just on the surface but also
deeper down they fill in weaker spots
where chunks have washed off or worn
away and all of this extra reinforcement
makes hair more like the intact hair
that was newer it makes it smoother and
stronger if you look at the ingredients
list of any hair conditioner out there
well almost everyone i'm sure there's
one out there that breaks this rule
there is going to be a cationic
surfactant these have names like
cetramonium chloride behantramonium
chloride disterodaimonium chloride
steramidopropyl dimethylamine and in the
acidic ph of a conditional all of these
have a positive charge and that positive
charge is really important because
that's how they work when hair is wet it
gets negatively charged opposite charges
attract and so these positively charged
bits of the cationic surfactant stick to
your negatively charged hair the
scientific term for this is adsorption
and the rest of the surfactant molecule
is oily and so your hair is now
lubricated it smooths it out it reduces
static these catalytic surfactants are
the default active ingredients in
conditioning products there are lots of
other conditioning ingredients too poly
quaternion polymers hydrolyzed proteins
oils and silicones and it doesn't matter
if they're in high-end luxury
conditioners or if they're in those
two-in-one shampoo and conditioner
products that people with shorter hair
tend to use all of these work by
sticking to hair so some amount of
buildup is good and necessary for any
conditioner to actually work but the
amount of build up is really tiny these
gaps in your hair are microscopic you're
not going to see these in a scrape test
so that brings us to the idea that a
product is bad because it weighs down
your hair
now what exactly determines how much of
a conditioning ingredient sticks to and
stays on your hair well it depends on a
number of factors what the ingredient
actually is how you use the product on
your hair how much is in the product
what the overall formula is how you use
the product on your hair and what your
hair is actually like and i think this
is really why there's this perception
that silicones can build up on your hair
and weigh it down if you use the product
that's suited for someone else's hair on
your hair so if you use a product that's
meant for coarse resistant hair on fine
porous hair then it can build up in your
hair and weigh it down and make it
greasy and lank and stick to dust this
actually happened to me right after the
first time i bleached my hair before
bleaching my hair was stereotypical
asian hair it was straight black not
very porous so i used an intensive
repair conditioner that had lots and
lots of dimethicone in it and that
worked fantastically but after i
bleached my hair the same conditioner
made my hair really limp and greasy so
it wasn't because my old conditioner was
cheap and bad it wasn't my sister still
uses it i have lots of friends who still
use it and love it it just became the
wrong product for my hair type it's a
lot like skin care products and skin
type if you're using products that were
made for dry skin on oily skin you're
probably not going to have a good time
and it isn't like my hair just hates all
silicones that's another misconception
silicones aren't all the same there's a
massive variety i found that my hair
loves products with different silicones
like amodimethicone and bisaminopropyl
dimethicone these are silicones that
have a positive charge so they tend to
deposit less on hair positive charges
repel each other so once there's enough
silicone stuck to your hair then extra
stuff doesn't stick on as much and so
the chance of your hair getting
overloaded with silicones is a lot lower
on top of this the same name on an
ingredient list could mean different
substances going back to dimethicone
dimethocone is a silicone polymer that
has oxygen and silicon atoms stuck
together like this but the polymer can
have different lengths and still be
called dimethicone and these different
lengths will have different properties
if it's longer then the dimethicone will
feel a bit thicker and heavier if it's
shorter length then it can feel more
lightweight and spread through hair a
lot more easily if you look at all the
different ingredients that are called
dimethicone that you can buy you'll see
that there are lots of different grades
and when i say grades i'm not talking
about higher and lower quality i'm just
talking about different dimethicos with
different properties that are good for
different uses so sometimes looking at
the ingredients list doesn't help as
much as we'd like it to when we're
looking for a conditioner that suits our
hair you need to look at what sort of
hair the conditioner says it's for look
at reviews from other people with
similar hair to you and try it on your
own hair so the moral of the story is
there are loads of different silicones
hundreds and thousands of them they can
be incorporated into hair care products
in lots of different ways just because
you've had a bad experience with one
conditioner with silicones doesn't mean
you need to give up on all silicones
entirely and if you do you might be
missing out on some really great
products that will work really well on
your hair i hope this video helped you
understand a bit more about what might
be going on with your hair care products
like subscribe notification bell follow
me on instagram check out my blog and i
will see you next time for i don't know
if it'll be sunscreen but it will
definitely be nerdy